it's that time again detective out the
latest games in new releases and this
week you get early access to the carnage
fueled world of killing floor 2 you
might remember the original six person
co-op survival shooter we're genetically
messed up clones are out for blood and
it's your job to clean up the mess the
second installment in the series follows
the story and now governments and
society have collapsed and survivors are
in hiding killing floor 2 improves on
the original with new slow motion
animated guns running at 120 frames per
second and various classes having 25
perks and new perk skills that you can
use to help your teammates based on the
developers track record we can trust
that the sequel will be heavily
supported but most importantly you get
this new gun called the Eviscerator and
it's chainsaw you know for well you know
it's in early access on the 21st
also this week you get the dungeon
management sim sequel from the people
who brought you tropico in dungeons to
fulfill the Dark Lords insatiable quest
for vengeance by recruiting fearsome new
monsters in the underworld as well as
extending your domination to the
overworld in addition to the management
sim the games now added real-time
strategy so prepare to defend the
kingdom against those annoying heroes
and then go above ground and put humans
back where they belong at the bottom of
the food chain start slapping minions on
the 24th a few ports this week helped
pan out the release schedule shovel
Knight makes its way to all things
PlayStation so you can face kratos ghost
of sparta destroyer of gods and coward
around shovels this game is beautifully
paced and nominated for two categories
in gamespot's game of the year for 2014
so if you haven't tried it yet get it on
the 21st life's a garden dig it also
this week insomniac the developer of
Ratchet and Clank and sunset overdrive
is sneakily releasing slow down bull
they've yet to release any gameplay so
here's some screens to tide you over
it's about a bull who wants to be an
artist but you gotta watch out for his
temper it looks cute but we gotta see
more I got this one off of vine the
Bulls in the china shop on the 20th
finally a musical RPG idle simulation
game Omega quintet is making its way to
the west on the 24th exclusively for the
ps4 you're managing a group of ladies as
they battle an evil force that plans to
take out humanity music will affect
combat and as their manager it's your
job to build relationships with the
idols and destroy the evil forever and
make super catchy cute songs matching
dance moves this one's for you ps4
owners get kawaii on the 24th for
further details visit gamespot com
release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week